all right today we're chatting with vlad
about
the metaverse right vod yes okay so
we've been seeing a lot of headlines
about the metaverse i've read some
articles
but can you break it down for me like
what exactly is the metaverse
the metaverse is something that if
facebook now met her
uh microsoft and epic games stopped
talking about
the rest of us would probably shut up
about as well because it's kind of a
label on a bunch of things that already
exist
and also
on the vision
this is where i can give you a more
concrete definition to what it is
for where things are going
and the way that i best understand it is
as a replacement for the web browser
so when i hear metaverse i think like
another world where i am now an avatar i
can create my own character so it's not
just that right is what you're saying
it can be
that again that's the way that has been
pitched to us from uh
meta ceo and founder mark zuckerberg
there was a there was a cute video
online actually where they took the
whole announcement of the meta
rebranding and
him presenting the whole vision
and then they just cut the number of
times that he said experiences
let's start by exploring what different
kinds of metaverse experiences could
feel like a lot of amazing new
experiences new experiences
experiences experiences experiences a
lot of experiences experiences and hand
gestures
experiences experience
so
that's kind of the point meta and the
metaverse is supposed to be the baseline
in which things build but let me get to
like more concrete examples of things
that exist
um
epic games fortnite
it's a really good example of how this
can develop more organically right
because nobody who plays fortnite is
thinking i'm building the metaverse here
like we're setting the template for how
it grows but they are actually because
first of all the whole idea of like
having an avatar living in a virtual
environment comes straight out of gaming
um
and fortnite is the best example of it
because people spend so much time and
money
uh time in the game and then money on
cosmetics yeah
niantic which is a company behind
pokemon go pokemon go is metaverse in
the real world so to speak right and
that company just announced this week
that they're investing in helping
developers create more metaverse in the
real world apps
i feel like with a bit more patience a
little less
overstatement
some of these things are going to come
together maybe what's going to happen is
we're going to have more of an
entertainment agglomeration such as
league of legends arcane netflix twitch
right way
streaming games
in terms of like
streaming a game from the cloud that i
can play and then streaming somebody
else that i can watch playing it and
then being able to stream an anime tied
to the game you know these more
interconnects between various
entertainment genres
i can see those
again building
into something it just doesn't make
sense to put a label on it so early yeah
okay so we shouldn't be afraid of it of
course not we could be a little bit
excited about it yeah but cynical yes